for the past year Travel Agency has
collected data about the number of
individual tickets that it sells for
signature product a Mediterranean cruise
the monthly data on ticket sales is
shown below what are the best and worst
months for cruise sales so what they've
given us this diagram this is usually
called a pie chart or pie graph because
it looks like a pie that sliced up into
a bunch of pieces sometimes this is
called a circle graph but pie graph is
much more common and then they say it's
monthly ticket sales so each of these
slices represent the sales in a given
month so for example this blue slice
over here represents the sales in
January and the way that a pie chart is
set up each slice is bigger or smaller
depending on what fraction of the hole
it represents so for example they're
telling us in January they sold 18
percent of the total year's ticket sales
in generous if you add up all of these
percentages it should add up to a
hundred percent and not only do they
tell us that they sold eighteen percent
but the slice of this pie should be
eighteen percent of the area of the
entire pie it is literally eighteen
percent of the pie if you were to eat
this slice you would have eaten 18
percent of the pie
now that out of the way let's think
let's think about their questions what
are the best and the worst months for
cruise sales so the best month is
obviously the month where they sell
where they have the largest or the
largest percentage of their tickets were
sold and actually I started with January
and if you just and this is what's neat
about pie graphs you wouldn't even have
to look at the numbers January just
jumps out as the biggest slice of pie if
you didn't even see the numbers if you
couldn't even read and you just looked
at this and someone said what is the
largest slice of pie you would
immediately say hey this is clearly the
largest slice of pie right over there
and so that is actually the best month
for cruise sales because they sold 18
percent you see this 18 percent is
larger than all of the other percentages
over here but it's clear just by looking
at the graph this is the largest slice
now what's the worst month for cruise
ticket sales the worst month well then
we just have to find the thinnest slice
of pie and if we look over here that the
slices of pie get pretty thin out down
here this is in the summer in June and
July
and in May but the smallest are actually
July and June and this is where the
numbers become useful because when you
when you just look at it by you know
when you just eyeball it you're not sure
hey are these exactly the same or they
just look exactly the same and that's
where these numbers are valuable and
based on the data they've given us it
looks like these are tied for the worst
in terms of ticket sales in both of
these months they sell only 3% in each
month so the worst months for cruise
sales are July and June July and June
are tied for the worst the best is
clearly January and then after January
the next-best on it they're not really
asking us add but since we have the pie
chart in front of us might as well ask
ourselves that what's the next best but
looks like November is slightly better
than December but in general in general
it's pretty clear that the winter months
the winter months do much better in
terms of cruise sales and these over
here and I guess people are looking to
get away from from the cold